well I it's absolutely true that I led a
wild childhood I mean I guess it started
at age six when I when I tore the the
locomotive for this electric train set I
just got him for Christmas apart to get
the electric motor out you know this was
uh you know I can't remember who told me
you could buy calcium carbide at
hardware store it was you the idea was
to put it in moles runways and the the
generates acetylene gas when when the
calcium carbide gets in contact with
water and so my mother was up fixing
dinner and and she hears this explosion
downstairs and she comes to the top of
the stairs I was in the basement and and
so I'm coming up the stairs cupping my
hands to keep the blood from dripping on
the carpet and and I was so famous for
practical jokes that she of course
couldn't trust anything I did so she
says if you're kidding I'm I'll tell you
there was an unwritten agreement between
us what if I did something really stupid
I would simply stop doing that and I was
usually quite happy because there were
so many things and there wasn't enough
time anyway